one question how do you bring up the
cheese 24 year olds a nine testa
filadyne came to Germany from
Thessaloniki where she studied social
work after graduating she couldn't find
a job so she took a big step and came to
Berlin to train as a retail salesperson
there's no on-the-job training in Greece
working and learning don't go together
is this a good system you know it's very
good because you get theory and practice
at the same time this health food chain
has two Greek trainees so far but many
more could soon follow trainees are hard
to find in Germany the manager is very
happy with his new employees they're
motivated interested they have fun they
enjoy the work you see that and that's
important to us
the two women say they do indeed enjoy
their work and that they made the right
decision but they're worried about
Greece and also disappointed that they
couldn't find jobs in their fields I
studied economics in Greece but
unfortunately I couldn't find work so
many people there can't find jobs young
people like us people between 20 and 35
have no jobs nothing
Greece's loss is Germany's gain not only
small businesses but major corporations
too are finding qualified specialists in
Greece Urmi Oni mimouna sees better
prospects in Germany than in her own
country some related to my studies I
mean computer engineering so I have many
options there money is in the field of
high technology very innovative and
that's actually the biggest reason but
what does the brain drain mean for the
Greek economy professor Nicholas
Apostolou polis came to Germany in the
1960s to study economics and stayed with
so many of his countrymen following suit
he says Greece will fall even further
behind it's a disaster the young people
are going abroad often unwillingly and
leaving a society behind that suffers
from the exodus of young blood and that
has repercussions for the economy
you can't modernize an economy with
older people the two trainees from the
health food store have settled into life
in Berlin the German capital is colorful
and multicultural they meet other Greeks
everywhere
for example the waitress in the cafe
her father originally came from the same
city the two women are from
all of them share a measure of
homesickness it's hard we're always
thinking should we go back or should we
stay when I first came my family said
come back if it's not good for you for
your well-being but now they tell me
you're better off where you are stay
there
just stay all right since the crisis
began some five years ago over 200,000
Greeks have left their homeland and the
young and qualified are the first to go